gym owners uh happy monday
hope this uh video reaches you at a good
time wherever you're at
um this is uh i think this is a very
important video that i want to make uh
it's been on my mind for probably the
last
month or two um but it became apparent
to me that we needed to
clearly state our position
i think it starts with context of where
the industry is at right now and then
kind of how
uh jim launch sees ourselves best
supporting the industry
and uh gym owners within it so right now
uh as i see it
from the various sources that i've
collected 25 to 30 percent of all
independent gyms
have permanently closed i believe and i
said at the very beginning that i
thought it would be
to 30 um but i think i was wrong i think
i underestimated how many more gyms
would actually not be able to stay in
business
and so i think that number may climb
over the next six months to maybe 40 or
even 50
of independently owned and operated
facilities
the reason that i wanted to start with
that is that
in the world of investments in finance
they have a saying which is in a
if you have can pick between a strong
operator
and a week in a weak market or a strong
market with a weak operator
in both cases the market wins which is
you can be the best
you know entrepreneur in the world but
if you're trying to figure out something
that helps newspaper companies
you're probably not going to succeed
because newspapers are going out of
business
and i'm not saying that gyms are
newspapers that's not my point
the point is more so that just to
illustrate growing versus static versus
shrinking markets
so where do i think the market is going
i think the gym industry has a very very
rough
next year ahead i think that the vast
majority of consumers as i said earlier
have
already had the opportunity to switch to
different
fitness vehicles i think that the brand
of fitness that we have to offer right
now
given the constraints in the political
environment and what we are forced to do
whether right or not are
our massive constraints on the business
right we cannot create the experience
that we have
wanted to create for our customers we
want to create a memorable experience
for them
and i don't think that the constraints
that are there give us that opportunity
i also think it creates
tons of variability in workforce and
labor because we cannot predict
uh how if we're going to get shut down
again or if it's going to reopen or if
there's going to be a spike or there's
going to be a new constraint or we have
to do
temperature or thermometers or this type
of mass or they have to you know
all of these different things massively
weigh into and i don't know if you've
just to illustrate this for you
personally i am not going out to eat at
restaurants nearly as much mostly
because i just don't feel like dealing
with the hassle
and i think that that is true amongst
many people who are looking at
coming back to service-based facilities
right now if you're looking at you know
if you're
a woman and you're trying to get your
nails done or you get your hair done or
any of those types of things
go in and ask them how business has been
right
they have the same constraints that you
know jim has and many of those people
would like to go back and have that
desire and yet
they have not and so i think what we've
done or what
what's happened in the marketplace is
that we've permanently trained consumers
uh to consume or fill this need in a
different way
and i think just by nature of you know
from zero to a hundred
if if we had a hundred percent of our
clients before this if all of those
clients are introduced to a new
type of service or a new solution for
this need an amount
greater than zero uh will stick with
that
and so i i think that the market overall
uh is shrinking and will continue to
shrink for the foreseeable future
so to put this statement open and clear
gym launch is loyal to gym owners we are
not loyal to gyms
my goal is to equip everyone here in
this community with the best opportunity
vehicle to package their skills
to be able to provide for their families
and be able to serve their communities
in a way that makes them healthier
that has been the goal since date one
jim's at the time for the last
three four years has been a vehicle for
that individual
which when put together with you know
the gym launch system
creates a profitable business for the
gym owner and creates a superior
experience for the customer
and helps people get healthy which is
the goal
to that end jim launch as a company will
be pivoting
and that is because i believe that the
best opportunity for gym owners
is remote for a variety of reasons i
think that
first off from a lead generation
standpoint for most small businesses
lead generation is the hardest thing
in a remote environment or an online
environment you have virtually unlimited
lead generation
you will never fatigue the united
states's need for
weight loss you won't even fatigue a 50
mile radius for weight loss
but a five mile radius it's definitely
possible right it's
much more difficult and i can tell you
this right now first hand
on the glx side the people that we're
working with for in person versus remote
they they cycle through the copying
creative at
three to four times the rate it burns
out much faster so there's more effort
that has to go in for a lesser volume
result at a higher cost
uh and the the lead costs if you just
think
conservatively if 30 of people are not
going to like people already have
excuses to not going to the gym when
they have no constraints
but if you add even a little bit of
friction towards something that they
already kind of don't want to do
then that constraint may double and
that's pretty much what we're already
seeing the lead costs on average across
all the markets for in person is about
thirty dollars for many people that does
not and that's for free offer right not
even paid
right that's average now some people
might be better some people worse but
this is just on average what we're
looking at
and so when we take these things into
account right we can get
way more leads at a way lower price
with less effort and more consistency
factor one factor two
the model itself how difficult
is it to implement how much margin
remains for the business owner
uh how does it enable the business
owner's lifestyle
in an online setting or remote setting
the business owner
can move and live wherever they want
they don't have to be
in a single area they can have freedom
with their family they don't have to
show up at the gym at four o'clock in
the morning they don't have to be there
until nine o'clock at night they don't
have to drive in for an appointment
to have that person no show and then
have another one at seven o'clock at
night that they just sit there and wait
for
right a lot of those things that we've
had to deal with as gym owners and small
business owners in a brick and mortar
setting
no longer has to exist all right
and very frankly i have always wanted to
figure out a way
to make online work at scale why
because you no longer geographic
constrained you're
far less temporally constrained and
financially
the model is more profitable period
and as a like just from the business
setting that would probably be enough
for me
but on top of that many people
achieve superior results in a one-on-one
setting
compared to a group workout setting
right many of you have hired tkn have
worked with trevor have worked with an
online coach
whether on the strength side or the
nutrition side or body composition or
whatever
and you did that because you knew the
one-on-one attention
allowed you to get a better result right
if you had to change someone's life
then you if they signed on and somebody
in your family were going to die
what way would you train them if you had
the option
of group workouts or one-on-one coaching
online
if you had to which one would you do
because if you say group workouts but
then you'd start doing the one-on-one
education that's not the model that's
not the question
the question is which would you because
that is realistically what we're
offering in the marketplace
all right and so i already said there
was enough of a case from a business
standpoint to make that argument
but on the fitness component side i
believe that the actual fulfillment is
better for the end user
and is more profitable on top of that
you have fixed margins in the business
you do not necessarily need to have rent
now if you have to deal with the fact
that you have rent
then that's a separate issue but the
business model itself
is not constrained by the sunk cost of
decisions that have been made in the
past
and the reason that i did not have
an online business model until covett
hit was one because we didn't have to
but two because no model that i could
find and i looked at
everyone's out there could be done
at scale by anyone without a superior
skill set
without uh having an authority or having
a following or
requiring an inordinate amount of effort
for example
there are three primary models that
exist in online today
excluding the glx model that i'm going
to talk about
vehicle one outbound messaging right
we have the cold messenger training i
bought two or three ten thousand dollar
courses i took all the best findings and
i put it into a course for 37
right you guys all have access to it
fundamentally why is it not something
that i see is
enormously valuable because it requires
effort
right simply put you have to spend
two three four hours a day outbound
messaging people does it work
yes does it require a ton of effort yes
can you
scale that not really right and so
that is opportunity vehicle number one
and if you've seen all the gurus over
the last 70 years
the reason none of them have an enormous
business is because the vehicle is not
that good
it's okay right with an okay vehicle you
can build an okay business
all right so that's vehicle one vehicle
two
is doing a webinar so it's building out
a sales presentation that edifies you
generating traffic online to register
for the webinar watch the webinar
pushing to an application that they then
schedule a call with you so you can do a
two thousand three thousand dollar
plus sale typically those models do not
make a ton of money
one because the webinar is fatigued two
because the cost per application is
extremely expensive you're looking at a
hundred dollar applications many
times three some of the people who are
who i know in that space
who are experienced only get one to one
two to one
up front on their ad spend with a high
ticket sale
and that's the people who know what
they're doing that doesn't seem like a
model that i would scale to others
third model is doing an online challenge
model
what that means is not the way that
we're talking about it but they do group
challenges
so that's where you tell everyone to
sign up for a group it's a five-day
challenge you make content day one
through four
and then you make a pitch on day four
and try and get a pitch on day three it
doesn't matter
the point is is that you're trying to
solicit people from a free group where
you provide value where you're
somewhat edified to then get on the
phone with you to buy some stuff
right um and that model is again
a very effort effort based model it's
very stop and
go it's very clumpy um and in my opinion
it's very difficult to scale which is
why you don't see any
massive online weight loss companies
that just do these five day online
challenges and i'm gonna say massive i'm
saying real massive not like
small personal bias i'm saying real big
businesses and so
because of that those are the three
models that i saw that existed
for people who did not have a following
and it was not a consistent acquisition
model and so i could not
put my weight behind it because i knew
that if i were to implement one two or
three or all three of those together
the vast majority of the people in our
community would not succeed
period it is what it is all right so
the reason i like the model that we have
now is that after all the trial and
error that we've been able to create
we can start a new business which is
essentially what this is
overnight because in a semi-regional
marketplace so it's the same state as
you
you have a certain amount of trust that
exists
with a free trial front end it does not
require a tremendous amount of skill
in order for you to sell it or scale the
sales to someone else
try and outsource a three thousand
dollar high ticket fitness sale
you're not going to be able to do it
well i can promise you all right if you
have any trouble outsourcing a 200
sale try out sourcing a 3 000 sale it's
not gonna happen
all right so the front end we know that
the acquisition is easier because we
have unlimited leads
that's massive for consistency of
business operations and for consistency
of cash flow
all right on the sales side or so on the
lead nurture side
allen has already solved this problem at
scale up to this point
you couldn't get 800 leads a thousand
leads a month and have
any any any dream of being able to work
that lead flow without two to three
full-time people
not gonna have it right with alan we can
do that
and we can set the price at fixed so you
always know what it costs to get a new
customer
right on the phone period for the sale
itself
for a free trial sale someone with very
very low skill set
can still sell a free trial on the phone
it is such a low risk offer
and so the magic of the model is the
fact that we have now found out after
this whole community has tried and
tested it
that the trainerize app that we've built
out my accountability right
when paired with a free trial person in
the model that we espouse which is
supplement sale number one and then
abandon hope number two
right both of those sales are easy
enough that you can scale them
and break even or come close to it on
the first transaction
and then by day 30 you will be able to
convert those customers at the same
price as you were able to before
in a gym setting except you have far
more of them
you acquired them for less and they're
staying at a higher profit margin
you no longer have to do sessions
there's no rent that you're
that you're you're forced to do and
ultimately there are many of you who
over the last
month have built out three or four
thousand dollars a month recurring
revenue that's in 30 days
right for those of you like marcia and i
hopefully
didn't mean to call her out here she's
built up forty thousand dollars in
recurring revenue
rawls built out another forty thousand
dollars in recurring revenue and she's
been doing it as well
all right this model if you give it one
month two months three months four
months
it is going to be far superior to the
the revenue
and profit that you were able to make at
the gym except it has no signs of
slowing down
right you do not have to be constrained
by your geographic
uh five mile radius if you've had the
desire to impact
your community in a much bigger way if
you've had the desire
to not be constrained to the five miles
around the location of your gym
that's only uh valuable to you when your
ads are converting
because you have the combination of ads
copying creative and placements that are
actually working in this specific market
at that time with the promotion made
which is real talk how it works right
if instead of having all that you can
virtually have an unlimited front end
and all you have to do is tweak the
skills on the back end that you can
consistently create because there's only
three roles that exist in the model
the person who sells the trial up front
the coach
and that's it right and there's you as
the owner
and so as long as you and if you wanted
to at scale you could have one person
does all three
right um but the point is is that each
of these roles
getting someone to sell free trial is
not difficult getting someone to convert
on a same-day offer they don't even have
to pay on that day which is like hey
normally it's 59 today it's 49 you don't
have to say yes right now or so you
don't have to pay right now just say yes
right now you want to use the card java
file
many people can make that sale for the
nutrition
hey don't need to buy all these things i
changed you get this stuff to get
started
right great most people can make that
sale these sales are not complicated but
can be done at
absolutely massive scaling retain a
customer
at a 2000 price point where you can
acquire them in high volume
very consistently all right and so i
need everyone
so i wanted to at least clarify this for
everyone in terms of where
jim watches position is in this
marketplace we are going to be serving
gym owners
and we're going to be serving gym owners
in the way that we know best and we're
going to align ourselves with the model
that's going to make them the most money
and very transparently i'm going to be
doing this
because i believe that i would like to
serve a marketplace that's going to grow
and make the most money because the more
money you make
the more money i make and you know that
i'm a capitalist at heart and
always have been transparent about my
intentions right my goal is to run a
profitable
wildly profitable business that grows
fast
right and so to that end if i'm in a b2b
space i have to align with a model that
i believe has the highest likelihood of
success
and profitable growth for my customers
and so for the foreseeable future
that is where gym launch is going to be
focused we're going to be focused
on bringing the online revenue to
everybody here and i can tell you that
if you have been on the fence
it is not going to get easier if you're
if you're if you're clinging to in
person it is not going to get easier
now is there anyone in this marketplace
that i believe is better at running in
person
no why because they all bought my book
to try and build their whole
temp coaching program right like the
business
the business mentality the business
models behind that system
are running in parallel we're using the
exact same skill sets the exact same
choreography of sales
the only thing that's changing is that
we're filling through an app instead of
in-person workout
that's it that's all that's changing and
so if you have the same five thousand
dollars to spend on marketing
if you spend that same five thousand
dollars for online clients
you will make more money simply put
it is easier right now to get 50 new
online clients
than it is to get 50 in-person clients
and i don't see that trend changing
anytime for the rest of 2020 right and
it
and the thing is is what i do feel is
known is that the rest of 2020 is going
to be [ __ ] for gyms
in general what is unknown is whether
2021 is going to get any better
and so it's i feel like i've been i've
been holding this back
i've been hinting at it i've been
alluding to it but i have not been able
to be transparent in the fact that i
believe this is the best model for this
community i've been always loyal to gym
owners
and i believe that this is the best
opportunity vehicle for you
to package your skills serve your
community serve your family
and in terms of roi on your time and
your capital
and the skills that you need to train
your team on this model i believe
is more scalable more profitable will
have higher roi
over the next six to 12 months than the
in-person model
the the fallout questions that happen as
a result of that is well what do i do
with my
my in-person business so there's
something called a sunk cost fallacy in
economics which basically means
because i've invested xyz before this
moment
i'm going to use that to cloud the
current decision at hand
right and so it's like if i've spent
i'm trying to um hopefully everyone
knows what sunk cost is but it's
basically you have a cup you have
you've made an investment that is
irrelevant in the in the variables of
the current decision in front of you
right and you're using that like i
committed to you know like i spent money
on xyz
and all right hopefully you get the
point
that being said if you still need to
make decisions about it you have a
couple of different
versions that you can handle this with
all right one is that you can simply
walk away
from your gym and deal with the
ramifications of that i don't think that
the court systems i don't think that
evictions and
creditors are going to be hitting hard
on businesses that
so clearly were affected by this i think
that we'll have
if there's ever a time that you'd be
able to get out of a lease this would be
it
this would be the time where you would
be able to get out
virtually scot-free and many of you
already have
the second solution is that you make
enough money in the online setting that
you can pay for it
because if you think about it you have
the same five thousand dollars that
you're going to spend
you're gonna have to spend it on
whatever business you're doing right if
you spent it
on the superior opportunity vehicle you
will make more net money doing that
and then you can still like you will
make more money doing that even though
you have this gym as your anchor
if you spent five thousand trying to
fill the gym up because you have it
versus spending five thousand dollars on
something else you will make more money
and still be able to cover the cost
better
because the opportunity vehicle is
superior
think about it let it sink in right and
so
anyways um my entire my entire goal is
always to make
people the most money possible is to get
is to give them the freedom they want
give them the security they desire
and i believe that this is the best way
for us as a company to do that and so
all of my focus will be to that end
i do think that we are actually on the
precipice and we're currently in
a golden opportunity era where there's
this huge amount of demand for online
services
and there's not a lot of supply i don't
know how long that window is going to
happen
but for the people that take action now
most of you already have but if you were
on the fence this is the time
to take that action what you don't know
is that many of our seven-figure gym
owners the top guys you see in this
group have pivoted 100 online
some of the guys who hear me talk about
their names all the time they've already
sold their gyms
and they've pivoted 100 to just going on
because they
sell all the math they didn't let their
emotions cloud the judgment
now i understand that everyone listening
to this is human makes emotions
emotional decisions and then
puts logic to them later so let me just
speak to your emotions
if you have the desire for more security
if you have the desire for less unknowns
in the future if you have the desire to
not have to worry about acquisition not
worry about
where your next customer is coming from
worry of whether or not your lead cost
is getting too i worry
about whether you're going to have to
have just another creative another home
run to save the month
right if you if you don't want to have
those concerns right you want to be able
to travel with your family you want to
be able to leave
your gym for god's sake you know i
didn't take a vacation for five years i
never even left because i was so afraid
i went back for for christmas and every
single year for three straight years
came back after two days because i
couldn't handle the stress of being gone
right and so if you don't want to deal
with that i do believe that there is a
time winder that we're in right now
where the entire marketplace understands
now what online training is
and there is a massive massive shortage
of professionals
who have the skill set like gym owners
right like
us we are all very experienced fitness
professionals if you compare us to
some guy who's interested in fitness on
instagram right or compare us to
uh even even to some of your trainers
right we're more experienced than they
are
and so if you want to do the market a
favor
let people work with the best
professionals and that's you
because they're going to do it anyways
and they might as well work with you
so anyways um to wrap this up
uh that is what all of my direction is
going to be on is going to be on
executing the model because this model
now
is as clean as a whistle in my opinion
you don't like this thing is as
just about as robust as the original gym
launch model
the front end offer is compelling we
will always be able to get people to
sign up for free things for weight loss
period that is something i can bet on
second do i believe that people can sell
free trials
at scale with low skill yes do i believe
that you can sell supplements to people
who want to
uh lose weight in a in a in a one step
in upsell environment yes do i believe
that
getting people to stay on continuity at
forty nine dollars a week thirty nine
dollars a week fifty nine dollars a week
is something they will do for one-on-one
training and support yes
do i now believe that people
prefer or value or get a superior
experience from a one-on-one
customized uh meal plan customized
workouts
in groups online yes i do and because of
those beliefs that i have and you may
not share those beliefs
but i've made some pretty big bets in
the past in this space
and most of them have been right and so
i'm asking you
to at least factor that in if it's
something that you're still on the fence
about
that you can at least consider the the
argument that i'm giving you right now
um because genuinely my interest is in
making you money
and so our interests are aligned it's
just a question of whether you believe
the vehicle that i'm talking about right
now is the best way
most of you already made this call but
that is what we're going to be doing
with gym launch and it's been
it's been very transparent that the
people who run that simple model
can scale and can make a lot of money
because the only thing you really have
to do is just make sure
that you're fulfilling the clients using
the app that
automates 80 of it anyways and that is
so much easier than having to worry
about trainers and sleeping with clients
and broken equipment and cleaning out
the bathrooms and
getting the right music like all of that
stuff is gone now or it has the
opportunity to be gone if you make the
choice
um obviously the choice is yours we will
support you at gym launch
independent of what you choose if you
want to rock in person we will help you
all right we've done it and i honestly
think you're like having seen and talked
to
most of the people in this industry with
half of them being ex-clients of mine
slash ex-employees of mine right with
half of them being that
i can tell you without any drop of
of doubt in my mind that we are by far
the best
not even close like there's not like oh
yeah we're like we are
ages we are eons above and the proof of
that if they were as good at business as
we are
then they would be bigger than us but
they are not and so i would say trust
the people who've been doing this the
longest and doing this the best with the
biggest
uh biggest reach and biggest data set
all right if you want to stay in person
we will try and set you up for the best
success but
given your skill set and your desires
and your and your wants and needs i
think that that same
skill set desires and beliefs would be
better packaged in this vehicle
the question is just whether or not you
want to take the jump all right
so anyways for those who have made the
jump i think you made the right uh the
right the right call hopefully this
entire video is just reinforcing that
belief
for those who have made that jump uh for
those of you not hopefully this
um at least gives you some transparency
you know why
we're gonna be talking more about online
why it's gonna be my focus
um and all the clients that we're going
to be bringing in are all going to be
gyms who want to go online and or
you know experienced fitness
professionals who want to go online and
scale
um because now for the first time ever
that's possible
right you couldn't do this without an
authority you couldn't do this without a
following
before this but now you can so um that
is
that is my perspective um i hope that
provides value to you i hope that
provides clarity
um in the direction of our company and
where i believe that the fitness
industry is going and where we're going
to be aligning
our company and we do that because
we want to align on the winning side and
i think that that is going to be the
winning side
um no one 50 years from now would say if
you're thinking about it known 20 years
from now i'd be like
man who would have thought that
in-person gyms were going to survive
this long
right that online fitness was not going
to be bigger 10 years from now than it
is now
right i don't think anyone's going to
make that argument and so i think that
it's
um it was time for me to make that that
make that line in the sand for us as a
business of what we are going to focus
on
um and that is what we are going to
focus on so anyways
lots of love um as always we're still
going to release plays we're going to
release you know the stuff that we do to
uh to help gyms because that is what
we've always done but i just want to be
honest about
what i see so that you can be on the
same page as me
you